do you think he should have served in
Vietnam well I have a pretty dim view of
his decision to use his privileged
status to fake a disability in order to
avoid serving in Vietnam you believe he
faked a disability do you believe he has
a disability yeah yeah at least not that
one he no I don't know I this is
actually really important because I
don't I don't mean to trivialize
disability but I think that's exactly
what he did when I mean when you think
about the way somebody can exploit the
system and needless to say the way he
has treated and mocked disabled people
is just one more example of the the many
of front Stooges basic decency that this
president has has inflicted on this
country but manipulating the ability to
get a diagnosis I mean if you were a
conscientious objector I'd admire that
but this is somebody who I think it's
fairly obvious to most of us took
advantage of the fact that he was a
child of a multi-millionaire in order to
pretend to be disabled so that somebody
could go to war in his place
and I know that that dredges up old
wounds from a complicated time during a
complicated war but I'm also old enough
to remember when conservatives talked
about character as something that
mattered in the presidency
and so I think it deserves to be [ __ ]
[Applause]